the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys 2 down bring your fate of Arya
Stark in the upcoming season her role
will be as important as it has been so
far but way more interesting are able to
finally arrive at your home will finally
arrive at Winterfell
but on her way home she will have two
encounters of which one was confirmed a
week ago arrival also by my theory
killed one major character will kill a
man that is among a few others guilty
for destruction of her family just as
she did in season 6 finale but now she
will kill a man that orchestrated her
father's death a man that set up a fight
between wolves and lions through the
Seven Kingdoms in a state of chaos from
which he personally benefited or it will
kill Petyr Baelish in season 7 finale so
with all of that being said let's just
jump into it well we've seen a lot of
leaked photos from filming set in which
most major characters took their place
there are only few leaked photos of
Maisie Williams if we can even call it
leaked which were taken while she was
preparing for the shooting while there
is not any leaked photo of Arya there's
one short scene from HBO's official
teaser of a new season which actually
gave us something in HBO's official
teaser we can see a few quick scenes of
which one scene includes Arya Stark
as we can see re on horseback wearing
North clothes in my opinion it's a scene
of Argus arrival at Winterfell
meloria knows exactly what happened to
her father mother and her eldest brother
she's aware of their deaths she doesn't
know what happened to her other siblings
doesn't know if her two brothers
bran and Rickon her sister sands and her
brother
aka cousin Jon are dead or alive she
finally came back home after all these
years of suffering and that's her face
expression with all emotions in it or
his arrival at her home is not
surprising at all since Arya told to
checking agar herself who she really is
and where she is heading a girl's Arya
Stark of Winterfell and I'm going home
it was easy to assume even before
official teaser was published that Arya
will finally arrive at Winterfell and at
we are going to have a full stark
reunion as I'm expecting the brand will
arrive at Winterfell
even before Arya before that reunion
happens or I will have more than
interesting trip to Winterfell full of
the encounters as my prediction a few
months ago was that on her way home or I
will finally meet will reunite with her
direwolf new media that she forced to
leave as she was afraid for her diary
rolls well being which was the
consequence of new media protecting aria
from the Prince Joffrey Baratheon by
biting Joffrey's arm this same
prediction came true a week ago with a
few photos the actress that portrays
Arya and the wolf that looks just like
the Miriah were in Canada last week for
season seven shooting may civilian so
spotted in Calgary while in the same
time there were wolves filming which
company by the name of the instinct
animals for film revealed and at the
same time confirmed with their post on
Instagram now of course that I wouldn't
say that this reunion is confirmed since
the same company doesn't only train
animals in this case both for Game of
Thrones series that could have been
nothing more than coincidence but not
only that this wolf was just like older
version of Darvill Cimmeria older
version of the dog who played Amira in
season one but also on the same shooting
delightful by the name of Quigley was
there the same vault that has played
Jon's direwolf ghost which confirms that
a shooting was for Game of Thrones
purposes as like this wasn't enough for
us to figure out that this wolves will
play any media in the upcoming season on
instagrok both they have also used
hashtag winter is coming which is the
official family motto or words of how
stark while Maisie Williams and both
were filming on the same place in
Calgary there aren't photos of those two
shooting together
this actors are not allowed to interact
with wolves and also need to be
digitally enlarged
those two loaves of which one that is
portraying John's dire wolf and one that
will portray our Desirables
are not the same animals that portrayed
all six variables in the first season of
Game of Thrones in which they are
portrayed by the northern Inuit dogs and
that's why actors and
actresses were filming together with
their direwolves in the first season
additionally when citizens one rep child
showrunners decided to replace dogs it's
an actual wolves and the dog feels as
dire wolves were offered to the young
actors who play their owners in the show
which resulted in sophie Turner adopting
dog that played lady now that we know
that Artie will reunite with her
adorable Cimmeria in my opinion the same
dire wolf will reunite Victoria by
saving her life this prediction of mine
is simply result of considering that
John's novels mostly appeared in crucial
moments such as saving the Lord
commanders life is whining at door
saving Sam's life from white and giving
a chance to the Lord Commander to
destroy the white with fire helping to
kill the wildlings during the Battle of
Castle black
protecting Sam and Gilly from two former
criminals in the Nights Watch that
attempted to rape Gilly and also was the
Fanning John's body beside his fact
there's even more important factors
going in favor of my prediction it's a
fact that the Battle of the bastards
took 25 days to film required 600 crew
members 500 extracts 70 horses and 25
stunt people costed a huge amount of
money but still director min well
support snakes that directed diet
episodes had to choose between Woodman
and ghosts as he said himself along with
the statement that it was a result of an
incredibly time-consuming and expensive
character so here's the answer for all
of us that wondering why ghost wasn't
protecting Jon with all proved that
immediately realized Victoria and the
toll of this fact being said I came to a
conclusion we can call it prediction
that numerous appearance will be nothing
less but glorious in the Miravalle
appearance save Arya as she said her
from Joffrey beside this at his point
confirmed encounter or evil also most
likely have an encounter with Melisandre
now signal Sandra is heading south while
RS heading north and dr. Melisandre is
prophecy that she told to Arya I see a
darkness in you and in the darkness I
staring back at me brown
eyes blue eyes green eyes eyes that you
will shut forever we will meet again I
can't see this encounter not happening
Aria did shut all of these eyes the only
remaining thing of that prophecy to come
true is no sandra meeting Aria again in
my opinion this messengers prophecy will
come true in the first episodes of the
upcoming season the question is how that
meeting is going to end well we'll have
to wait a little longer for that answer
but there are only two possible outcomes
in my opinion we know aria and we know
that she is dedicated to decreasing the
name since her kill list and we also
know the messenger is on that list the
possible outcome could be either Aria
Killa Melisandre utter which Lord of
Light would bring her back to life since
she has many things yet to do as she
says herself to John or Melisandre
somehow managing to convince Arya that
she saved John's life which will bring
her Orias absolution after an
interesting trip full the encounters or
you will finally arrive at Winterfell
were pond by my theory she's going to
revenge not only her father but her
whole family since Littlefinger is one
of a few men guilty for how Starks
destruction in league plot there stated
that in the last episode of the upcoming
season sense I was going to sentence
Littlefinger to death which Arya will
carry out I've already brought your
theory in which Littlefinger is going to
die on his first wedding night after he
married Sansa Stark doing that once and
as Littlefinger once so feel free to
check it out for more details if you
haven't already long story short this
theory of mine starts with Petyr Baelish
who did all he could to set sense as a
queen in the north betrayed Ned Stark in
order to set up a fight between wolves
and lions the man that also poison
Joffrey Lannister and Geoffrey's own
wedding with help of Olenna Tyrell to
save Sansa and then that same save girl
already tortured by Lannisters was
handed over to even more sick oppressor
Ramsay Bolton and only favored to turn
the north against the Bolton's and to
give him opportunity to lead the knights
of the well that he is commanding with
by manipulating young Lord Robin which
he provided by killing Robin
mother only Table two sets and sighs the
Queen in the North Littlefinger didn't
expect the John who is not even the heir
of how Stark would be proclaimed as the
king north by other northern Lords
that's all for the moment in which he
started making new plan a plan which
involves Sam sighs his life as a wife
with whom he would manipulate as he is
manipulating with Robin which would
provide him the Norden army and would
lead him one step further to conquering
the Iron Throne his plan by this theory
is to either make a conflict between Jon
Snow and the north or to arrange Jon's
death but also to make sure that this
time she will get the northern army
which marrying sense of the shirt the
same man Littlefinger will start his new
plan by marrying Sansa but at the same
time he won't be aware that sense is
manipulating him that Sansa and Arya
found out the truth about his betrayal
over their father which would the Hound
reveal to them as the Brotherhood
without banners is heading north that's
the moment in which the wedding between
sands and Peter's going to happen the
moment which will lead to their wedding
night which is orchestrated by two stark
sisters by Sansa and Arya as the
steering continues Wolfinger incense
after the wedding feast will go to their
room and while they're alone and while
Baelish things that his cunning skills
and his genius mind again resulted it
starts being manipulated in that very
moment sensible put a dagger down little
fingers throat the moment in which
sensible entered the room the moment in
which we have two senses the moment in
which area is taking off sense of space
while holding a dagger on Peters throat
whereupon Arya is killing him while
Sansa is watching and some kind of probe
that Arya is able to use face of someone
that is alive I'm a lying on the scene
that took place in the final episode of
season 5 a scene in the jerking her garb
or arias face who was standing just
beside him that she might confirm that
the faceless man assassins can bare the
face of a person that is not that a
person that is still alive which makes
this theory in which areas using sense
of space and is killing Littlefinger
well senses entering the room much more
possible and I have to admit this theory
would totally fit to the game of journal
series feel free to check it out for
more
details about this theory of mind let me
know your opinion that I brought you
today about Daria stroll in the comment
section down below
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace
[Music]
you